[ __ ] you didn't set it or not did not
see update hello hi everyone Resident
Evil I'm Mike McCarty here with dog but
university edu this should be the final
episode of Resident Evil 0 or according
this I think we're actually if you're
watching this we're publishing this
earlier than normal because extra life
is this weekend and I'll get more into
that in a few seconds excuse me dog but
here last episode ended up being the
penultimate episode unknowingly pretty
good 95 percent positive you'll beat it
within the hour
yeah yeah but so I'll talk about extra
life soon actually now I'll talk about
before we get in the game play quick so
this we're putting this up I think
Friday during the day so regardless
Friday November 9th yeah we know
actually sorry
GameSpot's extra life will have started
already on Thursday but uh-huh Friday
November 9th at around 8 p.m.
Mary and I are gonna take over extra
life and do like 6 hours or so of
resident can evil with Revelations so if
you catch that live we're gonna play for
like 6 hours we'll have a few good
friends on and guests and stuff from 6
p.m. yes so I'm coming on to just help
for the kids and then at 8 p.m.
Knievel starts yes and we'll be going
until like for about five or six hours
from there yeah you can't catch that
live do not worry the next day are not
the next day sorry
sometimes the week after we that will
just become a normal break out episode
number one of Resident Evil Revelations
right so we're gonna play it live which
is cool cuz we normally don't do this
live so if you want you get a special
treat to watch it live with us maybe
we'll do like seven participating like
Live Chat stupid the this is a letter
opener threatening sorry I was actually
gonna ask pleasantly for extra life
donations not threatening Lee just
kidding
we have some awesome fans for Knievel's
so we would love it if Knievel fans
could could help donates some come on
have fun with us we do it for the kids
we're having a good time
yeah let's be
this game yes but yeah we hope everybody
gets to stop by like regulars and help
support sick kids and stuff but again
otherwise if you miss it live don't
worry we'll put that up as episode 1 of
Revelations and then from there we're
just going to continue that game as
normal sweet I have to fix this yet
again I keep forgetting to do this
before we start so first thing Jen does
to get the grenade launcher Oh Lord
Observatory both of my peeps are like
not in great shape you said you're gonna
only take one anyway
so my thought was okay to not take her
because you know you're gonna come up
against it right to hunters I know from
mansion to the yes and I have all these
shotgun shells which I don't know if
they're worth I mean I certainly can't
take much more hits so I'll probably
like have to use them and then you'll
have but I need the space to come back
so here's the interesting thing is is
like you don't need the handgun that's
kinda does the grenade launcher not take
two spots it takes two spots yeah so I
need this health spray so I think I
might wait didn't you pick up a green
orb last episode that you could just use
right now yes and drop the health I'm on
orange caution yellow Daleks orange I'm
looking at I'm pretty positive that's
yellow it's orange okay anyway yes there
is a green okay how am i wait there's a
green plant right here so I could eat
those you could eat that to get back to
green from the yellow that you're on
right I'm on orange and it will turn
into a yellow caution if I eat those
do it you didn't use it
[ __ ] you were right but wait are you
both orange then yes but why did that
not even you're still the same color
that's how orange I was why does this
look weird
oh the screens facing was super that way
here let me help you
it's [ __ ] orange okay well regardless
so did I just like suck a plant down for
nothing no it still gave you health are
you sure to drop that I did not drop it
I ate it
you didn't suck it down for nothing I
did suck it down for you no I don't care
let's just go
you did that to prove me wrong and you
proved me wrong I did though that's the
value in right in universe can Oh balls
yeah cannon canonically it did not
really help Billy so there's a lesson to
be learnt there well what I'm saying is
there's a plant here let's make a call
there's another spray here so I it's
fine look at all these pills some pills
here yeah anyway let's go so I came from
up here and I need to retrace my steps
correct yeah go back to that ladder this
is like the final area yeah go back to
the ladder at the top left because
that's gonna bring you up into the main
foyer for yay oh yay which will bring
you upstairs to the observatory okay so
let me just a quick killed a lot of
normals arms last episode of tour the
other so I don't have a lot to work with
here I got 16 bullets 13 bullets
honestly because you're not gonna go
back through there I would knock the
hunters down with a shotgun and then
just keep going don't worry about
killing them because it's not one of
those cases was there one in here let's
think about this where am I going I'm
going to the elevator sorry I'm going to
the ladder or am I going into the same
ladder I'm thinking of I don't know I
don't know what yeah you're onto that
ladder
I just don't know what's in here and I'm
a little concerned about it worst-case
scenario it's hunters a lot of people
who shot guns can still be concerned
yeah like you can own oh yeah you should
you kill me killed
I killed da hai oh no the water that's
not the ladder I'm thinking of this is
the remember we did that water block box
puzzle yes so we gotta go out here and
then up these stairs maybe those ones or
the ones back by the save room I
honestly don't remember well take the
elevator down here you did take the
elevator down here
that's a scary area there's like not a
lot going on and it's scary yeah you
want to get back to the elevator which
will bring you up to the foyer a no to
the train crash do you think no thanks
I thought maybe he'd play alright so
down these stairs possibly I mean
there's not a lot of other things for
him to do man that stupid grenade oh you
know what we never [ __ ] figured this
out I don't think you're able to do it
yet so that's what you that's what we're
doing next so I mean you could do it now
look there's a dead guy there
okay so sorry so we're going oh oh well
[Music]
no monkeys no monkeys no monkeys okay oh
god yeah my what a journey I've been on
oops oh yeah this way
this was the water puzzle that was fun
remember that I stepped on a slide
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] where am I
am I stuck oh yeah
okay maybe it's the stairs Neosho
there's the dead end
can I get back yeah like I'm not no no
you're trapped am i no the point of the
elevator like is to allow you to
backtrack
okay so I'm just going all the way back
to the same room no wait wait wait wait
what I thought that story you just came
through I guess you have to go that way
you're talking up the save room yeah
where we started the show yeah yeah
was that biohazard or the door you need
the card for I wonder if that was up
there I will figure it out like what's
over here
what's that
that meant that many elevator check out
this has to be it
I don't know where we are
this is an elevator mm-hmm this is what
you're talking about right no I'm
thinking of the big elevator that you so
doing this might be leading back to it
let's trick them up I think that's it
straight up yeah is so yeah okay so left
nope my left
yes sorry yes okay I remember this I
forget where the monkeys are they right
past here
I can't there were monkeys there I can't
remember there's monkeys everywhere
yeah there's resale Billy go through
that uh right that's where he fell into
the soup all right you are going to
level one how sure are you
oh not at all I think it's one so you'll
come out whatever the floor you're
aiming for is the train crash room
monkeys monkeys monkeys
sweet now I just go through the sewers
like normal and then up the ladder oops
let's do that we could do that first and
then go back how do we favor go back
through the door for a second no one
checked him
okay so Rebecca got that red chemical
last time I believe yes she did
she acquired one chemical for sure
that plane trains been on fire for like
a really long time I think it would have
like run out of fuel
[Music]
poor Billy yeah if there's any other
health that I've like forgotten about
cuz I could really use like cuz like I
can heal up once I can like fully heal
but then I can't heal again which i
think is a bit nerve-wracking
alright is it in the where is it the
circular room so I think go upstairs
okay
behind the black and white scale thing
yeah it was like in here and left wait
was it there's two ways I'm oh that's
the classroom
yeah oh wait yeah so you go into the
classroom and then yeah so the hunters
are in the hallway but we knew this yes
like I said you could even the best-case
scenario you could down them with one
both with one shotgun shell and just run
that's a pretty best-case scenario I'll
do it she's gonna do it go oh my goals
to like not die [ __ ] they're like right
on the other side of this [ __ ] I hate
these things
oh yeah
just keep going oh yeah you might have
to get him on the way back I couldn't
help it I got scared
I'm trying to member if on the way back
last time you had to fight that second
one or if there's there's another way
you could go I guess there's a blue herb
I don't think you want that
there it is okay I thought it was the
hookshot
me too what's the other thing to your
left yeah what's the what else now it's
another blue I mean I can just look on
the map and see if there's anything else
so there's a green here that might be
worth getting where in this room no it's
here but it's on the way out yeah cuz
you uh yeah that's worth getting
yeah that's even more reason to go back
we came let's do it
you should probably save once you get
back to the original save room I agree
because I've done all this work yeah let
me just okay here we go
don't die don't die don't die okay them
all killed them you - can you pass that
white fan remote under that monitor
thank you um it's been a really long
time since I've seen it but you've seen
Casper the Friendly Ghost very long time
ago okay there was like I'm doing this
wrong the I think they were brothers
like the three ghosts that were really a
middle TV that one it's in here is no no
I guess either way oh there's no door
from that window what's that red
blinking one on the far left
Oh increments and cribs we don't need
those we don't need no stinking and
cribs anyway for you to know rib so
those brothers I liked vividly remember
like at one point a character like is
trying to say they're like nope
what's up isn't it yeah yeah they're
like ugly or something and they respond
in unison by going thank you and it's
really annoying
it's just sometimes I know how you
talking about thank you
yeah I wish I have everything says to
them you think thank them [ __ ] you get
it yeah get in go Birds I don't think
yeah at all oh [ __ ] I don't have room
for this might as well just use it then
yeah there you go your net gain sweet
golden [ __ ] you crows [ __ ] Birds
Billy did not expect the birds you know
I remember faintly like why didn't I
ever go in that room to get that uh
green herb right like you would
obviously get it so the fact that I
didn't get it means yeah it means like I
didn't want to go in there for a reason
I like forgot what it was it was Birds
it was Birds
alright so just back the way I came
and then to the south of the save room
that Rebecca's in okay and we'll have an
eventful thing happen okay not the end
of the game of clothes really yes I'm
still have a mint moonlight gondola ride
what are you thinking about resonable
zero having almost finished it I think
it's pretty good I've enjoyed it I think
um switching between players isn't my
favorite I said this like on the first
episode am I going to four yeah because
it doesn't make sense it's quite often
I've solved the puzzle but then it takes
me 20 minutes to execute it cuz it's
like oh she has the blue you know gem
and he needs it for the door so I have
to find like a way for them to deliver
each other goods and like I don't enjoy
that puzzle like that's not an enjoyable
puzzle to me I also didn't like the Box
puzzle it's very tedious
however the actions been good
I think the story's been pretty fun like
I like the fact that he's like a you
know a no-nonsense like murderer like
wanted and she's like a cop and they are
like we're gonna gather and I think that
it's a fun story and I think the action
is good and I think it's been fairly
scary yeah I remember enjoying playing
it a lot
I played the this on the origins
collection when it came out overall I
think this is a pretty good game people
were asking we're gonna play Revelations
on the ps4 port if you don't know it was
originally a 3ds game I love revelations
last time I played it but I'd use the
Circle Pad Pro for the 3s to make aiming
with Jill easier you spoke highly of it
and you also said that the sequel is
co-op which is pretty cool
yeah the sequel is not great it
originally launched as like what for
episodic four episodes you're going left
here yeah it'll originally launches four
or five episodes but they're each
different characters but I will be a
character whose only ability is to use a
flashlight to stun them until you can
come up and kill Dom's so I have to rely
on you which is not my preferred method
sounds great
yeah but we'll play that at a later date
another good thing about extra life
blowing through like six hours of
Revelations will be though quickly we'll
be able to play written remake to right
around launch if all goes according to
plan if all
which it never does in the show so
that's why actually life is like forcing
us to revelations like 10 to 12 hour
it'll be fun though to do an episode of
Knievel live because I enjoy that a lot
yeah we'll have Chris waters a former
GameSpot editor slash host god I love
Chris waters Kelly plague use our views
editor now
god I love Kali and also like from my
understanding knows horror pretty well
Jake Decker
and maybe Ben Janka who knows resin evil
really well cool but because it will be
over like six hours they might be
swapping in and out we will be in it for
the long haul yeah I have to go to bed I
feel bad Mike you originally were like
just let's just finish the game yeah you
wanted us like play all night but I have
plans on Saturday and I can't miss them
yeah I can't stay up all night even
though I wanted to and I feel bad but I
had obligations that I I promised
ages ago and I can't I can't yeah I'll
be doing extra life on an officer I
can't show up with no sleep and I can't
not show up yeah those are the world but
I will stay late and all I ask in return
is one calzone
everything for calzones that's just like
what I want oh I assumed you were
specific craving you're like Ben Wyatt
from Parks and Rec I liked them but um
actually no I think I find him so funny
on that show I think she's drunk
especially I think he's fantastic okay
so let's talk about this and I think
it's gonna happen I he's fine but like
look how limited I am with stuff like he
can either take this grenade launcher
here's something scary where the rest of
your grenades don't so you have six and
napalm ones right here start with me I'm
not [ __ ] going back why didn't you
ask no they were so they weren't just
like yeah cuz they weren't up in that
room hold on just go to your mat we'll
find him out I'm pretty sure we left him
near an elevator my [ __ ] god
nightmare you're not gonna need them yet
just so you know but that's not what I'm
talking about I'm saying like I'm just
gonna have to go back to this [ __ ]
facility I don't know they weren't they
weren't in that room that's why I'm
saying don't worry cuz you're not got to
go that far I'm pretty sure they're near
the elevator one of those oh there some
Oh
so first floor of the factory see that's
what's weird
that's the sixth one you got the Magnum
I don't know if that's worth that if
it's only six I mean a decent number but
I don't think you will need them make
the call on use the guy I get to the
factory I don't know
okay so that's not that far from it so
so that's right I'd say on the other
side of the cable car which would mean
my way that would be kind of a distance
but you six grenades I don't think
you're really good on health actually
and magnum rounds you have what like
nine eight eight seven total eight total
okay that's good let's just do this part
we'll see how it goes and I think I
think you're fine
so I'm gonna fully heal her that seems
like a good call right this is orange
maybe what's your what's it what are
your other health items that you have so
one first-aid spray oh she has it she
could just eat a green that won't that
only bring up the yellow are you sure
yeah you give you that and then there's
a food didn't what why did it not look
like you ate that I didn't see I don't
what happened last time when Billy it
didn't look it didn't do that I don't
know
never mind doesn't matter long there's a
range of orange anyway I know but like
the herb did a weird animation I don't
know so you got a first aid there
definitely pick up those grenades okay
so he doesn't have any room left so he
would have to get rid of his shotgun or
this first-aid spray like what is your
thought
honestly so you don't need the grenade
launcher right now but it's really good
to have down here so maybe dropping and
they launcher in this room really yeah
for context you're about to go up
against some and you don't tell me no no
no I know I'm saying you don't yeah
that's fine leave those bring shock and
child health there's a gun that's the
other hand gun right yeah Rebecca's got
the enhanced one she's fine balls you
don't need that handgun don't worry
about it oh you're getting the first aid
spray I'm trying it's not going great
yeah there's also that one on the desk
you might as well take just in case are
you serious you have enough room like
there's no downside to taking it what if
I need health later just don't use this
the Molotov I don't think you need
either actually yeah bring knows I think
you're set honestly you got full health
for both of them you're gonna come back
don't know he doesn't have that much
he's got ten shotgun Joel just trust me
he's fine
[Music]
alright let's go
you ready mm-hmm all right okay open the
map quick all right so move through this
next area relatively quick there's
nothing really to do it's a hallway but
just anyway don't hang out yeah okay
should she have a regular gun or her
magnum regular okay actually I would
lead the way with her I know that's
counter tutors what we usually say but I
want to save as many shotgun shells as
possible well he shoots randomly because
he's dumb like people pointed out in the
comments actually which it's kind of
late in the game to realize this but
it's kind of 'fl they don't always shoot
they shoot if you're shooting or if
you're like grabbed by azam but they'll
kind of rely on you to lead the way
right there ai is so mo if they're here
quickly I just keep going all the way to
the other end okay yeah go through there
so there's like a frog in the water that
can jump out at you there
it's way too long Watson come on see it
like a frog okay here's aam be so both
of you get on that lift and then so
don't fight these on these there's no
actually yeah yes yes yes do because
there's they're useful stuff again but
it's again rely on her no no no that's
fine but he only has like I know ten he
used them so yeah turning all attack off
on him I guess yeah just kill them on
the handgun
really Galloway you [ __ ] noise do
you hear anything more they're so naked
oh damn it why is normal industrial
waste being delivered here there's so
much poop here they're closing it down
alright Billy it's your turn to grab
these get some shotguns boom the tea
yeah why what is wrong with you chili
okay into the here both of you yeah and
then ready for some quad fighting
Colonel sink from vana brothers
I pull the Magnum out for her oh [ __ ] oh
and put Billy on attack oh sorry I did
okay so there's a door and then there's
a ladder do me take the door or the
ladder okay
this doesn't even it says I can open up
yeah Oh balls
oh yeah did that have eyes on it no
you've seen this before
it's the tyrant's again oh I killed it
though you thought you did I did think I
did just start Magnum in it when you
okay wait when he's recovering from the
shot he's invulnerable remember that
same as last time
yeah like just use the corners oh [ __ ]
run you idiot [ __ ] idiot I moved him
over here I'm trying I can't see him but
I actually can't see him just come back
hit him again
Magnum wants to show but he's in danger
no he's gonna die no should I heal boy
but well isn't she oh you mean her yeah
but don't stop
well alright he's gonna die
oh god I knew it I [ __ ] knew it
Magnum again
[Music]
save those just use a shotgun but keep
moving actually put so I just so she
doesn't waste anything I put whoever
you're not using on Idol at this point
he's almost dead
oh no sorry he's so dumb she's still in
attack just saying I mean I put her on
regular gun
nice and he's dead
ah and you saved a couple magnum rounds
- I did and you have yourself do you
wanna get that yeah or no I think you're
going back there after this section so
we're going down here now
I actually don't know I just told you go
towards the ladder so you would trigger
that okay well I mean you know either
way I obviously had to go down here for
something right there appears to be a
green light here yeah so you think
that's the last time you fight that
thing I mean I hope so pretty ugly
she's on coffee all be careful
all right that's it I guess
I wonder if when I was fighting that
thing if I could have pushed the button
and gone up the ladder I don't think I
would have taken too long
he would have just jumped you I mean
monkeys know movies movies
don't waste them on him oh god he's in
the way though yeah [ __ ] I thought
you meant the Frog um I don't know those
monster things you know they have one
that's like frog like oh yeah I meant
like an actual giant frog of course you
did
oh [ __ ]
what so he's full now yeah get that and
then go back into the previous room you
don't want to leave anybody out here
with the Frog but you do need to like
change the water level before you if
they both need to leave yeah okay take
the green herbs yes then run like hell
out no frog the frog
okay so what do I change the law was
that the button motherboard to do
something okay yeah but your map sure
I'm pretty sure you're going back up
that lift but what about here you can't
cross that yet cuz the water levels too
high so oh right that's right came from
yes and then I think that you can use
the motherboard up there this way
probably Billy here though you don't
have to actually I don't even know why
that would benefit you easier to
maneuver I guess without him well I mean
if there's danger yeah I just bring him
I guess who has the motherboard you want
Rebecca to have it so know what eyedrops
you didn't get on the list in time
stupid dumb idiot [ __ ] stupid okay so
I think okay so forward into the right
wait
no where is it in this room I think
around here ish okay that you can do
over there you click on there yeah
clicking everywhere oh there you go
gondola terminal yeah so the
motherboards for that this is the
gondola you were speaking so fondly of
gondola
[Music]
man Resident Evil loves their gondolas
yeah Renault 4 had one resident two had
one Oh God just in terms of like my life
I would hate this
I would not [ __ ] get in that
you know that they're like Gator cases
or cases that people use to like you
know ship equipment yeah you can put
like lots of sound baffling in or like
we're sorry just cushions that
everything's like nice and protected we
have like massive ones for you know try
casters and audio sound boards and all
these things that we use to for you know
III and stuff
and okay good found some Grenada's
that's good I'm listening grenades
mellow yellow ones trying to figure out
what the best if you should separate
them or right so she's just rides the
gondola home no keep her here for now
really there's a door here I know so she
shouldn't leave it oh so you know what
this is this is the other side of that
on door yeah you might as well do that
actually but get ready to shoot some
stuff okay [ __ ] like a lot oh not many
people good thing well anyway when we do
these shows and we have like these audio
board like audio or sorry these giant I
thought it was gonna be a zombie yeah
the knock-back is fine I always worried
that I'm gonna get stuck in one of those
sound boxes and die in there from like
suffocation like I don't like the idea
of like even having more melody you
might as well just keep her in here Oh
actually yeah take those there's another
item but I'm full yeah
it looks important yeah just drop
something to pick that I mean I guess
really yeah well I'm already keeping her
in here yeah so I can deal with it later
right yeah cuz I can have him drop like
see whether you're still he's not with
you no no yeah so she's the only one
who's in the gondola but she could open
up the door right for him to get in you
don't you
so just drop it like anything right now
you're just gonna mix that it's a
chemical that you're gonna mix oh I see
we got her
obviously bug related all right so I
should be able to is this what you're
talking about combining yeah with like
with your yeah that's weird
oh no that's the industrial water sorry
so so I'm just drop drop like the
grenades for this there's this here yes
that's the blue team so okay the mix for
himself here cast now combine the
sulfuric acid with I guess we're water
yeah I'm observing it god that's gross
looking water I think you just combine
that with your chemical set
so what did I make diluted sulfuric acid
solution is suitable to use as a battery
fluid okay to form the battery fluid to
bomb the battery fluid so yeah she's
good here no I think you just need a
bring him back here because that's the
battery little fluid for the forklift so
as Billy I would backtrack cuz you can't
cross the gondola you have to go back
alright yeah unlock that door
yeah I'm gonna switch the Billy and just
kind of regroup
I'm not entirely sure up the whip oh no
no no you're already up here
sorry through that door you're right you
woke up really early this morning for
some reason like oh [ __ ] the Frog
different oh you might be in here too
I woke up at like 7:00 a.m. for like no
reason and my brain just woke me up I'm
tired
okay I'm just going back to the forklift
room that lady we're gonna both back
noise this is for you babe
she's got some nice packs I'll say that
mm-hmm
the suction is just designed to make you
back sure I mean I know them oh come on
there might be another one down Oh Duke
city Adrian Peterson that was so lucky
though because I that's what I'm here
for
oh my god alright now what I think
[Music]
you're not do that door and then through
that door this door this door yes you'll
be in the fork room forklift room soon
enough get Oh
the fork room yeah almost made a bad
joke about the band spoon spoon room hmm
I don't think it's that way things the
other way if I were a collector
yeah come on come on back I think it's
the other way
I hope so cuz there was a lot of Ami's
in that room
oh maybe what's do the floor [ __ ] now
try this you're here where's this rage
came No
yeah try this you're here I don't think
this is where you're going I'm so
[ __ ] this is the main elevator laws
you got to go through the pool room and
kill one of those dudes okay I should
bring up a Scooby Doo
Sona so this way down the stairs is that
what we decided yeah in the pool room so
killing one of those dudes fast and then
just go
what if there's three where am I going
down these stairs right yeah okay well
then I want to kill this guy [ __ ]
you weren't looking I saw what I needed
to see I saw him he didn't even flinch
okay now just bring Rebecca here leave
him here he's safe
so she's gonna go through that door
what take the small tops I am gonna take
those small tops
I'm on fire
[Music]
I guess that's the only option where
these slugs keep coming from take these
stairs I'll squish these slugs I leave a
comeback take stairs just wish more
slugs as always sucks
you know I just threw that last door
that's it nope oh right
the box puzzle I know I've never done
this far I might run to the bathroom
before the final boss cuz you're coming
up on it and I drink a lot of coffee and
iced tea today okay but no well you can
keep playing so just do the forklift
battery fluid with her have Billy stand
on top of the crate and then just grab
the keycard um wait say that woman she's
got the battery fluid so I have Billy
stay on top of the crate that's on ya
and then she's gonna like pour that
fluid in there I guess okay on the other
side
did I I need a battery
appears as if I'm supposed to have a
battery so you have the battery fluid
yes I do
and yet no battery oh okay sorry whoa
large capsule okay so it's not too far
um it's not far at all how far is it
large capsules what really large
capsules um go back to the room we're
all right what's up those stairs
together or just one of us together can
he get off that without nose oh my god
he's so dumb if I go up these stairs
will he come with me
probably not let's find out oh thank God
I brought him though right
trying to think of where the battery is
now [ __ ] stay down
yeah where do the battery I don't
remember seeing a battery we've
obviously missed a battery
so okay cool we're not that far actually
um is it in the treatment plant so
you're you're both gonna go yeah you're
not too far um yes to this so go
where are you now I'm gonna hate me but
you're gonna have to go back to the
billiard room go back to the forklift
room and go through the door that
Rebecca came through I'll show you I'll
show you just right now go back across
this catwalk to the billiard room this
is the cat it's in the room where you
killed that thing's crop back then crow
oh wait no oh yeah so go down yeah yeah
this look over the billiard room no it
doesn't it goes to the room with the
forklift
sorry that was a billy room this goes to
the forklift room you want to go through
the door you're going the right
direction go to the door on this toward
the camera yeah but you need both of
them
oh yeah he's following okay he just slow
you're gonna go up those liche stairs
again all right this is the room this
might be the room No yeah through that
door and then this door
just run away cool so go down the stairs
yeah I never went down these stairs yeah
I was gonna ask you about that that's
where we shoulda brought Billy not the
forklift room but either way there's
like a battery case down there on the
ledge thing is there bad stuff in here
uh yeah I think so
what do you mean usually the battery she
just needs a booster up yeah but is that
bug gonna come out I don't know what am
i [ __ ] psychic just kidding
I don't know I actually don't it might
be something else useful in here no
that's one you shot earlier yes Skype
don't look up my dukes it's all I know
how to do your dukes complete me I have
a scholarship did should I look around
are we done wait Oh chief oh all right
well she's on orange caution so I
suggest well just reload his shotgun oh
that's good too but she's on orange so I
could exchange this with her and she
could eat it
thoughts sure feelings sure
I feel good about that
don't look at my dukes that's all I know
how to do your dukes complete me
why did it take you long so long to
decide I was thinking about stuff damn
it I knew it
don't waste shock until actually yeah I
don't give a [ __ ] do it there's two of
them there stir so yes or no on the
shotgun you figure it out I'm gonna say
that every time I don't really know how
king kill him
sure [ __ ] him up [ __ ] rude is what
that was shut up
I think of that there might be something
else in this room I'm not gonna say no I
mean I hope so because I would have just
ran up those stairs there's a door oh
sweet that's a shortcut oh no that would
have been a quicker way to get I see
basically it's equidistant so I don't
know just go back to the four cliff room
put the battery in and then you're going
back to like that hallway right there
on the other side okay
I've been waiting a long time to do this
amazing
now where was I I started this evil plot
[ __ ] Mike leaves for like one second and
I'm like where am I I always forget
where I am even with the map I'm like
there's so many locations and it's show
a web it's definitely my weakness to
finding finding like the location of
everything and navigating it like
Resident Evil 7's house got me so many
times where I was like where am i all
right now that we can do this are you
full
okay useful give these to this lady okay
hi so I'm at the location but I haven't
executed the order yet but I feel good
about it
wait did you combine it with this the
battery no I forgot thank you
so I assume
I thought that was um
Magnum ammo I was I don't know that's
like the ticket to your boss fight got
it
what was that noise am i nuts I just I
don't think I did too much they
understand sweet
nobody tongued me also I'm almost out of
shotgun shells that's alright you're
probably gonna give him the grenade
launcher for that final thing okay so go
back to safety no no way not through
that way go this way oh [ __ ] try
remember so you want to go back up the
stairs is that up the stairs thought it
was yeah I guess that didn't
billiard-room again no that's not the
billiard room oh wait I have no idea oh
it is the billiard room
[ __ ] yeah it's gonna get you back there
confusing game it's in the gun Dola girl
[Laughter]
Ava Cassandra says I am so pumped for
Revelations and a super long episode of
it good cuz you're getting it
what cook was I using last time someone
said they need a cup like the one I had
is it the one that's a black mug and
then every time it gets hot it oh right
I got Lucy pretty good without the other
day I was like hey if you see my black
ma I can't find it because it was the
Lord of rings map at the time wait did I
do this wrong I did this [ __ ] marry give
big jump yeah yeah I'm Steve in the
shotgun shells were in the morgue now
the grenade launchers in the observatory
that's true grenade launcher was one of
the other hunters last time
according to Machine great I think I'm
saying that correctly I know told me
before good res evil this operation
Raccoon City next it's not a thing
operation Raccoon City yeah that was
that shitty third person co-op shooter
it was fun for time maybe we'll get to
it eventually after 7 DLC and all that
yeah I take a left
oh wait yeah isn't this where there's
two guys I don't think so remember there
was two guys coming up remember you know
think so
don't act like you don't remember my
double Juke it was like here 100 100
percent agree about the precious baby
ears people people noticed my baby ears
because you said that I think she's
still gonna be stuck I mean did she get
hurt
I'd like to save yeah yeah I've
accomplished a lot yeah
now here's the thing this is my last
save e puck it's your last save puck is
my last save hug I thought you had
several so that's the last pile of them
but I thought there was more than one in
it
balls
let me put it down somewhere far away
what software do we use to record the
video like this in 30 seconds this is
xsplit plus a bunch of other yeah
excellent that was a question by a
station extreme okay cool yeah so
everybody's pretty pumped for
revelations it seems like that I think
that's an underrated game I mean people
who played it like it it's not talked
about enough it's very good this game
revelations yeah this too I like this
game but revelations especially more
about we do but not here
like I didn't bring all of my pucks
that's right okay but I think this is it
right yeah all right so I'm gonna get
this grenade launcher yeah give all the
grenade [ __ ] get all the grenades Billy
I'm really sick of this [ __ ]
um well she doesn't need the molotovs
that's a start
and also [ __ ] we left those yellow
didn't we leave those grenades in the
battery fluid room or did you bring him
back here
I think we did I have the yellow you got
off that grenade oh she just you just
took her from her yes sweet I swapped
them so he's got a full heal 14 Nate 20
nades did that math she's got a full
heal but she doesn't have anything then
yeah kind of cheap for a second mm-hmm
she's only got two magnum rounds and
four that will change soon before the
fight okay I feel good about this yes
[Music]
should have done this before saving I
always do this I save and then I like
alter all this stuff and it would have
been easier to like Bach maybe do you
want a molotov I mean it's fine you have
room with her I do actually I'll give
him to him if he has room swap pick up
the Molotov it's her and give the
keycard to her in the montage to him
though it's not gonna do anything
literally okay it's the item on the
right it's hard to see is the problem
I've like hidden
I like hidden the items in this room to
such a degree where when I drop
something it's really hard for me to
know what God did I do it
did I pick them up you like hit be on
accident
first circle whatever all right we're
good all right I'm going follow me if
you wish to live another Caspar
reference but it's also a reference from
a different movie The Terminator now
that's interesting
here we go and then next time someone
says that at all they could be
referencing Knievel which reference
Casper which reference Terminator I
don't know where I'm going you're going
the right direction okay actually that's
like in the office you know when Michael
does the Wayne Gretzky quote and says
from Wayne Gretzky but then he says
Michael Scott you don't talk about yeah
quoted Wayne Gretzky come with me if you
want to live and then Mary no it would
be Arnold Schwarzenegger and then it
would be Casper and then it would be
Mary and then it'll be whoever says it
it's not wait you heard about that
yes it's Friday give me a break okay um
what am i doing I going up this elevator
yeah
no way dum-dum
well what is that from that's from you
something I imagine probably why is he
having them all time to quit you know
you just never know would you like him
to have the grenades equipped because I
felt like this is a better solution in
case I panicked
all right so through the store I assume
yeah
there's gonna come a time where you're
gonna pretty much give Billy all of his
all the weapons the frog the frog if it
jumps up just move back again
so on the other side of this is that
door no no you idiot
no go yeah go it's fine just let it jump
back in or call flight oh yeah oh [ __ ] I
actually don't know what to do what do I
do
I only have multiplied Stu her when
she's grabbed what does that accomplish
them all time at least she just saved
repent yeah the AI was killed by a frog
yeah they should just saved that was
kind of funny it was worth it geez it's
horrifying she got swallowed whole that
was horrible Billy should have cut it
open and like been like he was like
running around with a multiple oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god what do I
do with this she's like tell me if you
want me to save you do something barely
do something do what look at what I'm
doing and change it fudge that was scary
I like really panicked but okay oh do
you do all that even Tory stuff again I
do
but good because actually you might just
they're more shotgun shells in the way
no you don't want the shotgun but doing
I don't know no you don't you were gonna
do the same [ __ ] was last time give the
badge to
okay budge this is why you do the
inventory menu save it's so stupid I do
this every time
take wait while you're here take the
give the Malton mulattos to him
drop her handgun ammo you really don't
need that I will after it perfectly pick
up the right items
actually no it's not gonna hurt just
bring it in that exchange thing I'm
gonna go with you need to [ __ ] I hate
this and you're saying she doesn't need
this ammo you might know keep it just
keep it and then if you need this we'll
drop something aside from the keycard
just drop that okay because her handgun
is semi-decent with the upgrade oh I
thought there's no hang on for a second
you can't tell until it's fully there I
know I think it's everything I think so
too
it's confusing I have 20 grenades Maul
Tov's and a full heal she has the key a
gun another gun a full heal so here's
what you want to do instead of be her
when you're going to the door because if
the Frog yeah then I can shoot it yeah
but if it it could she could eat me too
yeah but just don't it wasn't your fault
I was the AI so if anything
alright let's go down this entire path
again slug way the road to hell is paved
with leeches let's guess squish them
while you can
no I mean you know I mean have you ever
what you crush great for their feet
because I always see people doing that
TV shows and stuff I've never done it
why oh we re time up to make wine ya
know I've never done it no like great
porn alright yeah no I've never crushed
grapes with my feet to make wine
you
that's new don't go back up to get him
just switch to them then come down but
oh the lives down here you're at I don't
know why he's on it now [ __ ] is he doing
I do miss the days when you only have
one person to worry about here okay we
will be back to that sooner yep all
right so this way mm-hmm mr. frog room
this is the where this is where it all
went down in from this is me off
yes No okay go yes
Oh balls that could have gone much worse
I agree cool he's not carrying anything
I just realized he's like not equipped
with anything
oh [ __ ] she's I'm cautious I just eat
those sure
like should he have this a quilter well
do I need to kill them that way
I'm her now yeah I'm just saying I don't
need to kill them right oh that's where
you came from
did you dodge him you're goddamn right I
did wait where are you going now so I
came from here oh yeah you have to go
around to the bottom so that door you
just so I do need to shoot that zombie
that's just a shortcut back there yeah
so do you guys balls that sucks
move you idiot
look this is a [ __ ] nightmare [ __ ]
on Orange caution if I'm more health up
ahead
one would hope let's just go Billy
idiot there shotgun shells right there -
oh [ __ ] you're not gonna need that for
the boss well so tell me what to do
let me get them button you're not gonna
are you serious or I don't know make it
this real quick there's a zombie life
there's no I don't have a shotgun I know
I I am no I even though you don't him oh
my [ __ ] god no key card oh right
unbelievable what a sad fight this is
ominous
I don't like any of this
Magnum
all right so yeah
okay
am I going in here yeah yes get ready
he's not he isn't equipped with anything
we'll do that as soon as possible okay
Oh God she's also injured you joined the
party you are the guests of honor after
all it's your wake he's like who the
hell are you dr. Marcus no you can't be
what's going on ten years ago we would
tell the whole story I'm sorry I was
born on a cold day a dark day not too
hot
assassinated or two dudes emptied entire
magazines into you well both that
whiskey Westco mr. Westover
[Music]
acting I will take over your research ha
ha ha and then they dumped him in a
William Birkin however something
wondrous happened I think my grandpa did
the voice acting for this llll you see
as avala it took the t-virus inside of
my queen
years to procreate my new life
I live get it now I mean have my revenge
on umbrella you'll pay for what you've
done
yeah oh that's gross did he know that
was gonna happen him he looks surprised
all right equip the grenade align here's
Billy okay you're just gonna [ __ ]
actually give him but ya give reload it
so there's not just two shells like I'd
say do the gadget acid
now let me ask you this she wants the
nagging so you okay hon before you
unpause it what you want to do is move
them to opposite sides I mean you don't
have to but this will make it easier you
want to try to get them two opposite
sides so leave Billy on attack but leave
him solo on one side and then go the
other side is Rebecca just try to get
around go meet Abby Rebecca yeah just
shoot it with as many Rach Megan around
as possible and he will attack your mmm
Wyatt don't switch him to solo until
he's in position so you're running
you're gonna want to move him with the
analog we can okay
otherwise just shoot it does he
are we going this looks like good no
don't
bugging me oh my god Billy shoot it
shoot it with Rebecca
um okay is she shooting him yeah I feel
like that hurt him significant okay
that's fine
yeah but she's an orange caution yeah
you'll have more heels what do you mean
in the future so he'll just don't want
to grab you again
god damn it Billy you it shoot it you're
not shooting it actually he's on orange
caution tuna thoughts also he hasn't
shot it with a grenade launcher once he
did it once right the beginning yeah
wait a little you am i hitting it yeah
made the noise
yeah
[Music]
you might want to check your health I
don't know what it's all right
also they're Magnum rails up there yeah
you're still good he's on orange but
just keep me I'm moving in a circle and
shooting it like you did with a pirate I
don't know where he is
if you hit one more wall and break down
there's that Bai
I'm Billy I can't be her right now I
like actually yeah yeah wake up
the [ __ ] camera angles the camera
angles they're moving it go the other
direction then what if you had the
chance so annoying
I like it's extremely frustrating ok
he's empty ok I just like I can't
effectively holy hell like I can't I
can't move them at the same time very
well it definitely seems geared to be
moving the other way which is annoying
wait we just we're here til you round
the corner yeah
I can't see where he is
he's missing you
okay right there stop and wait till
around that clock dude it's the Koran
Allah my fault nice cuz not that's done
you're good you're good but it's not
over yet
Oh God okay there were magnum rounds at
the top of the room yeah I mean just
pick up all the [ __ ] in this room who's
that he dropped those wait
don't pick those up yet I don't know if
that triggers anything okay there's like
magnum rounds through there to the right
we're both sit there up there
I believe nope yeah don't think oh I see
them cool okay okay easy drop keys yeah
he's almost out of Granada's I hope I
didn't need those for anything else
he's got three that took a lot I know
you that you have more stuff coming huh
okay all right now what tell me I want
to go through the frog alley
trying to think of their inventory oh
there's a red door here and a savory
items bun yeah okay so here's my
proposal all right is it leave someone
in here and go back and get the shotgun
no you don't have to okay actually you
know you know what you're right
go through go through the next to the
next room to the same room yeah save get
all the ammunition and [ __ ] in there and
then we'll see if you could beat the
final boss without the shotgun otherwise
you'll have a save to load it back up
but I don't think you will
dumb make me use two different types of
keys oh they both have to do at the same
time you need to go no you just need to
use them on the right one the silver is
on the left well you both I understand
Howard's that might have been the
opposite way you need to do I think
Silver's on the left oh maybe not
I know what key goes where and yes I do
and I find this rude
cool
[Music]
do all the inventory stuff first right
let's
[Music]
so do you want me to go back and get the
shotgun I don't think you'll need it but
like it's gonna be annoying if you do I
just say back yeah just leave Rebecca
here and go get it as Billy the Frog
won't be a problem with one person okay
but leave Rebecca here okay should i I
should have a gun then now how many more
times do I save cuz I could save get it
and come back that's you're not you
super annoying if you're getting no no
don't save if you're gonna get the
shotgun just go get the shotgun then
come back but you're not gonna runs
anything else but how many more times am
I gonna see it cuz I get three ink ribs
this is your last this is so I could
just save go get it and come okay just
in case I'm just sayin am I gonna save
no no your reasoning makes sense okay I
don't want to run our ink ribs but at
the same time I actually think we've
we've accomplished a lot in this game
and I don't want to go back true
[Music]
that's my fault for not wearing the
shotgun again I don't think you'll need
it but you might as well just so we have
a better chance on the first try
I mean I don't know it's just it's
essentially just to give Billy some [ __ ]
you with I forgot to make her stay you
can keep her in the next room - it's
gonna be said are you sure it's just
like kind of eerie in here I'll check it
out with the leashes yeah don't move you
idiot all right it was in here yeah I
just want to like also get those shotgun
shells in this walkway on the way back
um okay
how much room did I give myself all
right you're good anyway yeah but you're
getting shotgun there's the shotgun two
spaces yes just drop the will equip the
handgun why'd you go back cuz I'm gonna
just drop something in this room yeah
drop them anywhere in this man thought
the show was eerie good sweet now go go
go weird doorknob it's a long episode
yeah we're almost to the end
so if I'm alone and the Frog licks me am
i [ __ ] technically but only if he
grabs your ankle but like he's easy
enough to avoid like if he does jump out
just reset why are they here where am I
did I go the right way though this what
you mean ah no that's where it came from
I walked up the stairs right um go back
down you guys are even any other way to
go once you go back down I got it oh
this is the capsule room I don't got it
this is where the battery was right yeah
Oh buddy wrap again
yeah you went too far you want to go
through that side while you're doing
this um Nathan Shepard has some some
stats okay
as yeah as of last episode you had 18
health recoveries that sounds so 3 last
episode chewed on by zom 22 times yeah
kills 120 so that's gone up by like 10
ish great new frogs the project project
project Argonauts frogs are cooking he's
probably gonna pop out appearance night
is not that balls it's like playing
don't wake daddy or [ __ ]
jack-in-the-box yeah no it's coming I
know he's out there swimming around he
just looks so dejected
I [ __ ] hate my life I would too if I
was him yeah it's a rough path they've
traveled
in here I think yeah what a journey
what a long journey to get to this point
yeah I don't like you with that letter
opener just hanging out it's like really
weird what is that Oh IV a lunch sleeve
oh my god okay this was a journey but we
did it
[Music]
I should have told you oh you know if we
have room though we didn't cool
the it's done I got a shotgun now new
shells and more shells and safe room
with Becky
oh the jump scared the beginning of last
episode was pretty good when you were
saying you shot the timer in the Wiener
and then the 100 oh yeah that was scary
they always suppress oh there's a I
can't see him that's the problem
the birds got me this time
remember the birds oh yeah not expecting
those birds
okay
when you went to the bathroom I was like
on my own and I was like where the [ __ ]
am I how many times I play this game how
long I go through these corridors I'm
like where am I I don't know I thought
you'd be done where am I going off to
the food no frogs no frogs do frogs
maybe since you can kill the first days
of
Robles that you're drinking why does it
look weird yeah what's the bottle what's
up at this bottle it's um like flavored
water but it doesn't have any sugar in
it brought to you by our sponsor at hint
it is not but I wasn't going to because
I checked them out that's why we checked
them out and that's why it has been a
really long time did you like the new
season did you watch it I have not
watched the new season
there's no reason it's just I haven't
gone around to it I didn't hate that
fourth season the one that was edited
totally differently yeah I thought it
was cool that they tried something else
definitely exhausting to watch again but
save once more and then let's let's do
this bad thing this way just sitting
there in a slug room so there's more
heels here so let's do the thing that we
do and let's organize our stuff first
no I get your logic but if you're if you
lose this fight you're gonna have to
like I got it okay
so do I need maltose do I need a grenade
launcher should she have the grenade
then
like here's the thing like she has a
like I don't need all this stuff right
like I so she's got a magnum so I don't
need a handgun farts sakes I'm ready to
pick up some other stuff first
[Music]
it's she gonna take the shotgun and he
takes the grenades what's the plan oh
she wants to Magnum and give him the
shotgun and grenade launcher okay but
yeah she wants a magnum and that's fine
there's not gonna be any room for like
heels
he should fully heal
he is he we have more than enough to be
the molotovs I'm gonna heal him
okay so give him the grenade launcher
okay
oh I see the problem the grenade
launcher the shotgun both take two slots
but you can exchange mid-fight you just
need to so maybe so like I can she can
hold the ammo and give it to him
mid-fight no it's like this is a better
system and then check this out I'm
honestly wondering if it's worth no
worth leaving that's wasting so much
space with one grenade in one Magnum
around I agree if you do need help is
the paramount in this next fight
what nothing I just saved a space what
you do yeah but I don't think the grid
and having her have the grenade is gonna
cuz I'm not positive you didn't switch
mid-fight maybe you can tell you to
leave that one grenade one grenade or
one mag round I don't know what which is
more powerful that's a good question
I'd say leave the one grenade okay so he
has 14 shotgun shells eight grenades
he needs a health item and he needs a
health I just give him that first day
spray and then you can pick up the rest
of her and she's gonna combine these
[Music]
do you think
[Music]
okay and then she's going to come in and
then she's going to she'll have another
spot with after this he'll just so you
know well I mean Oh balls sake for now
just do the ink ribbons and save yeah
that last space can be your flexible one
I guess Molotov is not terrible I mean
it depends on like how dane endanger
like oh i did not i don't want to do it
[Music]
painting my buns alright yeah you might
as well drop the ribbons and get them on
tops
[Music]
[Music]
then so he's got the grenade last her so
[ __ ] in one mag around so annoying
I think this is fine it's good I think
I'm ready if I have him equip the
shotgun he hasn't anything quite right
now yeah are they both on attack yeah
sweet
get on here I'm not even messing with
that [ __ ] you thought all brawn no
brains that'd be funny if that they just
like put all the Sam on here but really
that was you've already
what a twist
dudes with sleep tattoos with douchebags
let's fight on a small platform it's the
Queen protect the green Billy who let
you touch machinery if this thing move
any faster
okay just [ __ ] BB Rebecca with a
magnum okay
this will sound obvious but your main
priority is to just preserve okay so
yeah you're good with her should I put
him on solo no you gonna stand still
again [ __ ] doc he does yeah I don't know
acts independently a partner I guess so
yeah try it baby
I honestly don't know it's fine but just
[ __ ] shoot it and remember it's
invulnerable when it's reacting
well you want to shoot it well I know
but I was training it away from it oh
[ __ ] I'm already hurt oh my god I don't
think he's shooting it he's only gonna
shoot when you chew that's what I said
earlier in the episode she's already an
orange caution that's [ __ ] crazy
is he gonna die shoot it you're not
you're not like attacking it
keep fit in your camera
what are you doing I don't know where I
am you're nowhere near the boss but am i
safe he's not though let's go shoot it
Oh see like why don't you let the master
work okay
I think you're doing well oh boy he
looks like Bongo Bongo okay that wasn't
good
surprisingly he's still fine so should
she get the shotgun or no can you switch
from here no you maybe you need to be
closer yeah they were trying to get next
to him anyways well use those
slugs hate fire that's not the end
no balls really so you're gonna want to
switch so al you'll see new bongo bongo
from the shadow temple boss and in
ocarina that's what his face looks like
I can't place it
but it's ain't I on a neck with like two
floating hands I do remember that okay
can't heal son well to me they always
look now your venus flytraps okay so
he's gonna do that no she is your you're
gonna be doing I decide this you make
Rebekah do it if you have a choice
because he has a grenade launcher and
the shotgun he might be out of traffic
you ya window so okay what are you the
chance pause it yeah [ __ ] yeah you're
gonna okay best are you gonna do nice
just keep it away from Rebecca while
she's to open the heliport
in-case-of-emergency follow the
procedures below you know you don't need
to worry like I don't know why they're
there are four locking mechanisms in the
room which must be activated in this
order Southwest Northwest south east
west side
what's I don't know you're screaming how
do you know which one that is how do you
know which one is this I know which
one's Southwest Northwest the east west
the south west one will be on the
southwest side of the room the map look
at is she at the southwest now I
honestly don't think you need to work
okay
Southwest Northwest south east west I'll
remember it's okay
so what you okay Alton mainly what you
want to do it you're just buying Rebecca
time while you lure it away from you and
when you need to shoot it shoot it so
I'm moving away from her you're just
keeping the monster away from her yeah
okay if it goes toward or shoot it's not
like you wanna I'm gonna kill her it can
you give her him that grenade or no it's
not gonna make much difference I don't
know if you can heal her now no I cannot
I might as well he'll I guess yeah
so yeah it'd just be him and her oh wait
we're the Queen away so she's gonna turn
that one
[Music]
yeah like I know you want to like get it
to attack Billy because you're not gonna
kill it sorry you're not I don't know
what I'm doing you want it to attack him
so get in front of it and lure it away
there you go
just keep this one okay so is she going
there automatically I believe so but
yeah be more get in front of it
[ __ ] I'm doing at this point literally
just make it attack you she can't get
out of there there you go keep doing
that yeah get it detect buck wasn't my
proudest moment he lets her really she's
only on orange she's been getting hit
enough of that
nicely all I can't stress this enough
you just want it to attack Billy I know
you're not you keep getting it to look
at you and then you run away the thing
though I understand what you're saying
but you're not doing it it's just not
executing well you're not executing the
way you're supposed to
I know like your attitude you're not
listening to me you're I am listening to
you not a grown him you're getting at
I'm trying to okay oh yeah I might as
well give her them in the Molotov to you
I don't think she's gonna do any
attacking why would you want to swap
yeah that's weird
you're in good shape yeah
like she see I'm like running in front
of like ice but today they just keep
like yeah
[Music]
there you go honestly that's fine you've
got a full first-aid spray is she stuck
no she's doing another valve all right
I'm on orange do you think I'm okay yeah
just you get have one more yes he like
hit it yeah now it's it's on you that's
two you got two more nice it seems like
you have its attention now it's Billy
which is good
[ __ ] I don't know where she's gonna go
though yeah that's when she's moving
then now what a terrible possible it's
definitely annoying and I'm like out of
[ __ ] like ammo would it get when
Rebecca gets a near it shoot I think she
oh my god she's [ __ ] so stupid [ __ ]
maybe he'll is Billy or did you already
cool [ __ ] nicely yeah maybe PA listen
just to be safe okay
holy [ __ ] yeah okay so wait wait wait so
each time you hit it with a Molotov it
staggers it so like make sure you don't
use it at saralyn yeah if you have a
detention don't even use one right now
just get it to follow you is it I don't
think I can it's on she's on the other
side of those stairs you're actually in
really good shape
[ __ ] I got stuck there I like staggering
I need you yeah now we understand no I
know it sucks yeah one more
you're gonna time you got two minutes
I'm not good on health and I'm not good
on I know but you're doing really you're
doing fine
honestly don't even nice Rebecca why
does she need to run straight into it
god I hate the AI in this seat like yeah
I like can't help her right now she's
yeah you might need to use the mouth off
I feel for you because wow she's an
idiot
Rebecca there you go yeah yeah yeah I
can't stop what's going on there I can
get in the way he's fine honestly she's
on orange I don't know but just get I
know it's all my body in the way it's
out of your control but that's all you
can do right now
I like wish I come on can I punch it
Kevin [ __ ] bad-ass I'm like trying to
punch it so you're doing it you're on
fine I think you got it like I keep
taking the hits right she's not that's
alright no it's not alright she's gonna
die well I mean it's better than you
this is not good sorry I just pausing I
know I'm like stressed out don't worry
about it just take this she's almost
there
that's so [ __ ] uncool yeah yeah I
stay on the left side ascend if you can
can you locate the [ __ ] thing yes
boss fights terrible this sucks
that sucked game isn't good that like
that's such a [ __ ] anticlimactic
shitty thing to do yeah so I wonder it
no we can do it this time yeah you're
fine think so we didn't do anything
wrong it's trash and I just needed to
know you know the only the next time
trash I will yeah I will say that like
now that you know I mean it's totally
out of your control sometimes but now
that you know how to get to get its
attention like just get right in its
[ __ ] face at the beginning because
he's so annoying though that like the
way that that just occurred and do I
have to do the whole boss fight again
yeah but like it was it was quicker than
okay in theory it's me what just
happened
so these maltose were good yeah but also
like the hand gun I wonder if the hand
gun will stagger it you know I get its
attention more room is the problem what
does he need yeah it's unfortunate about
the Magnum and the grenade but if you
feel strongly about that I could get 16
bullets for that magnum handgun right
not the Magnum yeah whatever
yeah I say that might be better I just
don't know if it staggers it you know
because you're not worried about damage
later you're trying to it's all
attention yeah definitely at the Molotov
I would give those to him right now
actually I don't use them until later
yeah you just need it's hopefully you do
get the chance to go near her again
I'm gonna do it cuz I don't think it's
damage based it's about staggering later
on it is perceptions damage right but I
don't think use all the grenades oh
right okay
so yeah he probably wants to handgun
then oh my god I I'm actually mad about
that fight I'm really [ __ ] mad not
good because we had a really good like I
was in a good position at the end of
that game that's why I'm mad I feel like
I feel like I was like kind of you had
no choice I mean there's things earlier
now that we know how to get its
attention more we'll be fine
give I think that give that to him I'm
so sorry he doesn't have room yet yeah
I'm like in a bad mood now I'm actually
like mad about what just happened I feel
like I didn't know it wasn't perfect but
I feel like I did good enough that that
should have been that and to like have
it end like that like I still maintain
you weren't getting its attention or not
at the beginning yeah I [ __ ] heard
you the first 30 times you told me but
you keep saying you did everything right
you didn't I do think I did everything
right I knew to get its attention you
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
this games gone downhill Hey look bright
side we're about to beat it pick it up
yeah the same relies too much an AI I
think
like an entire game focused on having
two people inventory management and
she's so dumb that she walks into the
bad guy like it's very frustrating just
I hope you could you should be able to
get this I hope so I don't know how but
start or touchpad oh this isn't a
cutscene yet it is how is this not a
cutscene it's like it's not like
cutscene I guess try other buttons maybe
yeah
oh she's not moving or had to have some
weapon a question oh okay wait sorry I
just told her not to follow me which is
not what I meant to do yeah
she wants this am i her I want to be her
I think I don't know you're both on solo
team okay
[ __ ] she got it I just don't think it's
staggered it's just unfortunate get up
oh you come on you're gonna see aside to
me you've never seen before if this [ __ ]
doesn't start oh my [ __ ] god what a
nightmare
oh nice touch so you're Rebecca right
yes I never [ __ ] counsel
[ __ ] I'm gonna have to yell
really it's so trashed
you're saving way more I'm gonna neither
the last time already if you're if
you're close enough maybe you should I'm
gonna become him now wait what is his
inventory look like oh he's got a
grenade anyway
[ __ ] just drop you might as well drop
that drop oh yeah but then take the
handgun and the amo this is not the time
that's so stupid you can't drop that no
I cannot use all this yeah just use the
shotgun shells I guess yeah I can't [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you Oh what's he doing
something who knows who does oh I'm
sorry
try dropping in the grenade launcher now
[ __ ] he was doing yeah okay sweet now
are you close enough to get the handgun
I might just say you don't worry about
later yeah
yeah
just makes me [ __ ]
we're G why is he so strong all right
wait keep skip this one yes I can skip
all of them I just want to live yeah
what a terrible boss but if you need
them if you need a tutorial halfway
through I'm so mad yeah
this is it paying attention you I don't
know you're gonna you're good to me it
really looks like it's gonna hit her no
no you're good that's one
oh [ __ ] yeah okay sweet she didn't take
any hits okay wait wait wait wait so
stagger it when she's yeah well fine
there's like nothing I can do in this
scenario yeah shoot it now yeah
so yeah it's you guys stagger it like I
mean I know it was it wasn't your fault
I think well I'm trying to help you
chill out
no you're being a Mike during the
resonable 5 playthrough right now she's
on orange give it I'm gonna give it a
bit you're in really good shape compared
to last time yes
[ __ ] you I staggered you and got around
you didn't I did I not did I not should
I wait yeah one more hit maybe yeah
where we don't even shoot it's not even
paying attention so weird
like four is too many
why don't you stagger this is better
than the shotgun or the gun and the guns
my last saving grace try to keep it over
here she's gonna go up those stairs
nice that's actually really good timing
I think you're still good to go hon
orange I don't know where yeah where'd
she go I don't know she's dumb as balls
oh I didn't think of the fact that she's
walking more slowly yes it's on you
that's good that's good that's good just
[ __ ] jukka's watch as possible over
here okay I'm gonna die I know I know I
know what's going on alright that's my
last heal for him she's on three I
believe she has a red and green she's
having I know
because he stopped paying attention to
me
that's three so I just need to stagger
it enough
gorgeously see look it's fine [ __ ]
kidding me
it comes over this way you're good
it's [ __ ] nice she's almost there
she's gotta be yes okay
believe it or not this is really good
because last time you both got stuck on
one side which was the I think you got
it
I mean I'm stuck here on green yeah it's
going after you can get me a little bit
I think I I don't know he'd son bite you
piece of [ __ ] oh my god bucket I hope
you like UV rays [ __ ] I was so mad at
this game this is it there's a bad boss
fight Oh Lord
wait where does this now there's just a
[ __ ] 44 out of nowhere how shoots him
in the face bull's his brains out
fitting ending to it okay that was
pretty bad I know I'll be the first to a
minute know though mr. McFee knee I'm
just glad that they didn't make you
shoot it I didn't have to play it
he's dead
I thought it was done
well oh I thought he's reloading the gun
hey Billy I need those you're still
under arrest I don't know what you're
doing hey that must be the old mansion
that Enrico was talking about they're
staring at a [ __ ] colored pencil
drawing what else it's time to say
goodbye what happened to his handcuff he
just threw he just I don't know how he
took it off but he just threw it into
the ravine Oh mr. dead
yeah just a zombie now
weird
let's go check out that mansion actually
Rebecca does go there she's [ __ ] yep
that's the piano room stuff Thank You
Rebecca
[Music]
it's pretty cool seeing Spencer the
whole of Spencer mansion from that was
cool a terrible [ __ ] boss fight that
was not a good ending uh I got really
frustrated with the AI there so here's
south side to me to add to what you said
it the fact that you spend the literally
the entire game trying to save ammo and
health so health mattered in the end but
yeah the ammo didn't you weren't doing
damage it was more about it was stacked
like yeah stopping him right
either way I'm let's do a grade you got
if they created it you'd say did you say
no where does this rank what what what
is your ranking now I forget I think
seven was my favorite then remake then 4
then 2 then 3 then 3 more than Veronica
then 6 oh well sorry I didn't put
Veronica in there I would say Veronica's
better than 3 but not as good as - I
used to think of 0 is better than
Veronica I liked watching you plays
Veronica I thought Veronica was better
than zero I enjoyed ronica yeah
I can't believe I got an F on what huh
Resident Evil was it for no that grades
each individual chapter I think it was
no it must been three it might have been
one or two because I remember like a
post-credits scene not sure obviously
they love doing that [ __ ] you probably
skip this right now
I don't want to you want to watch the
credits no because I'm afraid if I skip
the credits I could skip the uncut scene
okay fair enough
I'm just like nervous about like the
rules here yeah that that came also I
think relies too heavily on it but while
we're on the credits and there's nothing
going on go to intro real fast it's full
screen I want to just explain about
extra life which is happening this if
you're watching this when it first goes
up its to extra life this is already
happening because this is going to go up
on a Friday so just know that you can
catch dog bite University and Benna
dukes gum Bourbons oh I see good one I
got him nice I said the whole season but
I got you
have you tried before the Dukes
cumberbund went to the bathroom once
before on this season didn't I yeah when
the clowns were here oh no I didn't go
to bathroom I got up cuz the clowns were
here
I didn't read that first yeah you did it
so I looked at your own joke before you
looked at mine it's fitting I guess on a
serious note while this is happening
again November 9 Extra Life a GameSpot
if you don't know what extra life is
it's a video game marathon fundraising
charity that goes to Sick Children's
Hospital in this case you see Benioff in
the Bay Area all proceeds will go to
them through extra life through
GameSpot's every penny account it'd be
awesome if Knievel regulars could watch
us live for the first time again if you
can't no sweat we will be that will be
recorded and archived on YouTube as
episode 1 of resident revelation so
you're getting a two hour finale and
you're getting eight hours of knievel
this weekend I just maybe more depending
on because this was like two hours the
next episode will be Resident Evil
Revelations 1 the debut very good game
I'm excited for a lot of knievel this
weekend so I start on I start at 6 p.m.
and you we start knievel at 8 p.m.
Pacific yeah so again we'll have a few
guests on to play with us and early on
YouTube it'll also be on Twitch
it'll be on gamespot.com is it
definitely yeah ok gotcha
because we don't stream to twitch it
much anymore do we no but you're
streaming this one too well it's good ok
and all Capcom whoever we forgot and
threw in the rest ok
is there a scene
yeah we know who Shinji Mikami is I get
it thanks Shinji shin he thinks Mikami's
on careful yeah I'll be fun obviously we
have some awesome viewers for Knievel so
if you have a like a dot anything
honestly we'll help
that'd be awesome if we could say that
the Knievel segment got the most
donations that is not my intention or
plan or motivation I'm just gonna play
some Kamini yeah but still I would like
to raise some funds for Sick Kids let me
know but either way will complain live
and then we'll archive it on YouTube
afterward like they really strung these
out at the end beautiful either way
we'll see you a report card deep past ya
109 kills DS get degrees kills 109 wait
what oh so so Nathan's counting maybe
Nathan's counting the ones that you'd
get before you died or wiped maybe 28
recoveries 620 shots that feels like I
didn't think you did that money sweet
you past 12 hours that's about how long
revelations will be but much better
paced got it
revolutions probably oh I'm very
impressed I can now play leech hunter
yeah you can play as um you get Wesker
mode that's really we at some point we
should do like some sort of I can't
promise anything obviously but we talked
about like bonus episodes we want to do
Wesker mode yours overpowered superhuman
weird it's pretty fun cool well thank
you guys very much for hanging out we'll
see you again this Friday bye
[Music]